[Music]
hi my name is Susan I'm the senior
culinary manager here at tasty and today
I'm going to show you how to make my
aunt's version of bun meat with
lemongrass quark so this recipe comes
from my aunt her name is Matt my aunt
has always been one of the hardest
workers I've ever seen ever since she's
moved to the States from Vietnam I
remember being a little girl and she had
a been me shop in Seattle and so I never
went hungry anytime I wanted a bunny fix
I could just walk over to my aunt's
sandwich shop and load up and it kind of
was where I agreed to love this very
traditional Vietnamese sandwich since
then she's moved away from Seattle and
now is based in the Cypress kind of Long
Beach area and she has another fantastic
sandwich shop called sandwich house she
is the person that gave me this recipe
to make but I've made a couple of small
adjustments to make it a little bit more
move there's a couple of key components
to the recipe the first one you want to
get started are the pickled vegetables
because those take at least one day to
get all pickly and delicious it's very
very simple it's just carrots and daikon
so daikon is a long white radish which
is actually pre mild in flavor so it's
perfect for the use in a pickles
application because it really takes on
any flavor that you add to it and what
the salt and the sugar and the vinegar
do is just come together to draw out the
delicious sweetness from the carrots and
the daikon and it's just the perfect
addition to the sandwich because it kind
of keeps the sandwich really nice and
light so in this recipe for the
lemongrass pork you use four whole
stalks of lemongrass and it might seem
excessive like it's a ton but really you
only use the center of the lemongrass
which is the most tender part and you'll
add it to the dish after you cook it
down to kind of soften it up a little
bit cuz lemongrass even when cooked
tends to have a little bit of a bite to
it so you definitely want to cut it
really really fine and then saute it
just to kind of further soften it so
that it tastes the best it can in the
dish so I fortune feed media
I'm gonna age myself out like right now
but I do ports and food media for about
15 years but last year when tasty asked
me to make my version of fun I actually
jumped at the chance because up to that
point I had actually never been asked to
make a dish that I truly believed in
that was part of my culture and I
thought that was so amazing
tasty was actively trying to make
content that was really diverse and it
showcased Asian cultures so what I do
that's a little bit different from my
aunt does is that she actually doesn't
use fish sauce which to me there is no
that means recipe that is complete
without a little bit of fish sauce so I
add a dash into the marinade and that's
just my little secret and will like
never tell her ever so my aunt uses pork
butt for this recipe because it has a
lot of nice marbling that runs through
it and it stays really juicy on the
grill and it's really hard to dry out
well that's marinating you ready cook
down a ton of lemongrass and onion just
until it's softened and it lightly
caramelized then she adds it to the meat
after it's finished grilling and I
thought that was just super super smart
and kind of puts you in more control of
how the vegetables react in the dish I
decided to do this by me sandwich
because I feel like bunnies have been
growing in popularity you kind of see
them in a ton of different type of
sandwich shops not just bunny shops you
know in Chinatown or Little Saigon
you're actually seeing them on menus in
even American sandwich shops which i
think is really exciting because I think
it's saying that people are really ready
to try new cultures food and different
flavors and I think it's a really
exciting time in food another secret
that we won't tell my aunt is I add a
layer of whipped pate to my bun meat
it's something that's interesting
because my aunt doesn't find it
traditional but for me it's just past
any part of it that means I think
sometimes when certain foods are what
people will say it's westernized people
see it as a bad thing and I don't know
that's a bigger topic for sure but I
think that what it's at least telling me
is that people are are ready to try new
things even if it's not the authentic
traditional way that I grew up having it
it is saying that people at least know
what about me is I don't think that is
the case 15 years ago
ABM is such an exciting time before the
Asian community because I'm just showing
you one recipe from my Vietnamese roots
but there's so many other cultures of so
much history that were able to celebrate
during this very special month I love
sandwiches so much and bunnies really
are my absolute favorite
oh oh yes